failure is not an option forget him out
we've saved millions of lives father
Chavo we've got motorcycles perhaps I
need a new vehicle ASAP this is an
overwatch operation our team is engaged
in a higher form of patriotism it's not
a military operation the goal is to
complete the mission at any cost we do a
week on a beach you're never gonna do
something normal until you die that's
what this job is I'm not you you're
pretty close besides this is my Beach
feel the sand between my toes
sir you ever walk in Boise that's my
asset local Special Forces sent him to
medical to see if he's recess he is what
is your name Lena are you involved in
acts of espionage yes I have information
that proofs my government is planning an
attack on the United States you have no
idea how evil my government is
lutely under venta to us it gives you
everything it's like a drive you're
going up against this country's elite
tactical squads back right down
no one ever enters a war thick and they
will lose but one side is always wrong
I'll give you some advice
you ready stop they miss that plane we
have failed they miss that plane they
are death company
[Music]
failure is not an option
we get him out we save millions of lives
requesting hand of God coming down
you
you